uh my name is Javid and I'm a
student I would like to ask a
question at one place the Holy Quran
states that man is Created from
spum which is Inc consulate with modern
science but at another place it also
states that man is made from
dust Now isn't the Holy Quran
contradicting itself or is it consolate
with modern
science the brother Paul the question
that one place the Holy Quran says that
human beings have been created from
sperm which conat with modern science
The Other Place human being is cre from
dust can you prove it scientifically
sced from dust and isn't their
contradiction one place firm one place
it says
dust the Holy Quran does say as I
mentioned my
talk
in 75 verse number 37 to39 it says that
human beings have been created from
sperm which has been
proved by
science the Holy Quran also says in
Surah 22 verse number five that we have
created the human beings from a
quintessence of
dust today's science tells us that all
the elements that are there in the human
body they are present in lesser or
greater quantity in the soil in the
earth so the statement that human being
have been created from Earth is
scientifically proven that whatever
components are there in the human body
the constituent the elements they're
present in the earth in the soil in
lesser or greater
proportion the second part of the
question isn't a contradiction one place
the Quran says man is Created from sperm
one says from dust is it in
contradiction see a
contradiction is two statements which
are conflicting with each other
which cannot take place
simultaneously the Quran does not only
say man has been created from sperm and
the other place from dust It also says
in Surah furan 25: 54 that man has been
created from water you will tell me that
three
contradictions see science has proven
that man has been created from dust as
well as from sperm as well as from water
if I tell you in one statement that to
make a cup of tea I require water in the
second statement I say to make a cup of
tea I require tea leaves or tea powder
it's not a contradiction I require both
if I want to make sweet tea I add sugar
to it if I want to make panicum tea I
add less water and more milk if I want
to make Suman tea I add only
water so there is no contradiction when
the Quran says human being is Created
from
sperm and dust and water it is actually
Contra
distinction what's the meaning of Contra
distinction Contra distinction means
speaking two or more things about a
subject which are not conflicting with
each
other for example if I say that this man
is honest he's kind and
loving it is contradistinction but if I
I say this man is always a liar and a
truthful person then it's contradiction
because both are opposing if it's not
opposing it's called as
[Applause]
contradistinction next question from the
ladies
section asalam alikum brother my name is
farida Ansari I am a laboratory
technician
Quran says Allah is the creator of the
human being does science agree with
it the sister POS a question that the
Quran mentions that Allah subhana wa
ta'ala is the creator of the human
beings thus science agree with it and
Quran says in several places including
the last verse of theological stages
that is Sur M 23 verse number 14 that
Allah is the best to create
can we prove it
scientifically that Allah is the creator
Quran gives the answer Quran gives the
answer in Surah chapter 52 verse number
35 it poses a
question that were you created from
nothing see the Arabic word used for
Creator in all the vers of the Quran is
it derive from the Arabic
word Arabic word kalaka has got four
meanings one meaning is to create
something from nothing without any
previous example that's only possible
for Allah subhana tala second meaning of
kalaka is to create something new from
pre-existing
material the third meaning is of kalaka
programming or planning and the last
meaning is to make smooth so Quran poses
a question in Surah 52 vers 5 that were
you created from nothing but naturally
the answer is negative no human beings
aren't created from nothing the POS the
next
question were you the
creators or we the
creators we know very well that man
cannot create another man if he could do
that in the moment he died he would have
created himself back if his relatives
would have died he would have brought
them back to life human beings can't
even create a living creature such as
fly live human
being neither can you attribute the
organs of the body say the reproductive
organs like testes or ovaries that they
are the cause for a creation but if you
say that the testes the uterus Etc are
the cause then you have to include your
ancestors their reproductive system
their ancestors their ancestors all are
responsible so the answer is negative
Quran PS the next question in Sur
chapter 56 verse number 58 and 59 that
do you not look at the sperm you have
emitted were you the Creator or we the
Creator and but natur all these
questions that Quran poses the answer is
negative some people can say it's by
chance by chance you were created they
say nature nature natural thing it
happened by chance let's analyze
scientifically whether the human beings
can be created by chance
the protein molecule is a very important
structure of the living cell very
important part in the living structure
of the
cell the protein molecule consists of
five elements the carbon nitrogen oxygen
hydrogen and
sulfur and there are tens and thousands
of
atoms required to make one molecule one
atom has five elements carbon nitrogen
oxygen hydrogen and sulfur there are
tens of thousands of atoms which make
one protein molecule and there are
approximately
92 free
elements the chances that out of these
92 the five will form an atom and these
atom will form tens and thousands of
atom to form one protein molecule was
calculated by Frank alien and he said
the chance is a 1 in 10 raed to 160 you
know what is the meaning of 1 in 10 ra
to 160 if I say 1 in 10 to 2 10 to two
means 1 0 0 two zeros one in 100 chances
is 1% if I say 1 in 10 to 3 it means 1
in a th000 that's. 1% if I say 1 in 10
to 4 it means 1 in
10,000 means 0 1%
so when the calculation was made 1 in 10
to 160 it means
1570 then
one and Mathematics tells anything one
in ra to 10 ra to 50 it's counted as
zero furthermore this is talking about
one molecule and the substance
required to form this one molecule of
protein was calculated by another person
Charles guy
that it will require millions of times
of substance as huge as our galaxies
millions of Galaxy will require to form
this one molecule of protein and the
time was calculated by Charles guy the
time taken for one protein molecule to
be formed will be 10 ra to 263 years you
know what is that 1
00 263 zos it will take to form one
protein
molecule and do you know there are how
many protein molecule in one
cell and do you know how many other
molecules are there in the cell and how
many cells are there in the human
being there are more than 6 billion
molecules when a child is born that's
what doctors tell us today 6
billion one protein molecule takes 1 in
10 ra to 160 chances time taken is 10 ra
to 263 years to take 6 billion for one
baby imagine and how many women are
pregnant there are millions of women
pregnant at a time and it takes only 9
months the chances science tells us is 0
0 0 no chance at
all these thing cannot take by chance
they have to be programmed by someone
science tells us there has to be
someone some Supernatural Force
therefore science as I said said earlier
is not eliminating God it is eliminating
models of God